can you imagine how much easier business
could be if you and I could be in seven
different places at the same time now
obviously today we don't have that
technology so until that happens we got
to figure out how to build remotely
today in this episode I will talk to you
about how you can lead multiple teams in
multiple locations and be effective at
the same time so let's first start off
by looking at this year I'm going to
give you two examples one why is it that
most entrepreneurs only do well with
businesses that are within 30 yards and
then what do I mean by this you run an
office everyone's around you it's about
30 yards here 20 hours this way you do
them at about 3000 square feet and we
can manage that but we have a very hard
time building remotely nationally so
let's look at the pros and cons of each
one pros are building within 30 yards
won lots of control
so most entrepreneurs start off being
control freaks for the most part not
everybody but for the most part the
whole reason why you become an
entrepreneurs you want to control your
destiny all these other things you also
like to control what everybody does
right so the pro is you get to see
everybody you get to drive everybody you
get to be the heart because you're
around everybody so they feel the heart
but you are the heartbeat accountability
it's easy when somebody's doing
something asking where the right eye can
be walking in the hallway and somebody
walks by me and say hey were you out for
the day what did you do today quick fix
there's an issue I can solve that issue
right off the bat sometimes there is
office politics there is arguments going
on there's differences there's friction
if I know it I can say let's have a
quick 30-minute meeting and that can be
solved so quick fix low turnover because
the closer they are to you turnover will
be typically lower however there's one
big con the big con is exponential
growth which means expansion so the more
you control whatever you control more
grows less whatever you control more has
less possibility of exponentially
growing and exploding and you don't mind
doing that in the business but you also
got to make sure you do it properly from
the beginning so when it explodes its
exploding on the right fundamentals
instead of just exploding without having
any kind of standards or expectations to
grow on
so now remote pros and cons Pro you can
scale multiple locations International
National East Coast West Coast Midwest
South it doesn't matter I can be all
over the place I can build independent
leaders attract different personalities
because some people like to be remotely
running their own businesses they kind
of want to be left alone so those
personalities the solopreneurs will be
turned on by this the con lack of
accountability lack of emotional
connection boredom sometimes people that
are working outside remotely from you
they get bored because they're not being
sold the vision regularly say they don't
see it on a daily basis they get bored
and last but not least low retention so
you have low turnover as a pro here
higher retention you have low retention
here so now someone could say well Pat
this is exactly why I prefer doing this
this is exactly why I only want to build
within my vicinity my office everyone's
close to me I don't want to build
remotely I will challenge you there and
tell you from my own experience for the
first five years of my business I only
build within thirty yards because I
wanted control because I have to know
exactly what everything was doing and
then I made adjustments made a lot of
mistakes but finally figured out what
things you have to do for this to go
from here to here so let me explain to
you solution number one before you open
up anyone to be remotely in another
place always have a two to four week
on-the-job training field training
shadowing whatever you want to call it
have somebody come and watch how
everything's being ramped have them
watch how things being the systems the
protocols the sales flow anything that
it is that a skill can be passed through
somebody else have them sit through it I
used to tell myself I don't do any
behavior unless of somebody sitting in
that office with me to watch exactly
what I'm doing if I'm making phone calls
I want five people around me to see how
I'm making those sales calls what's the
purpose if I'm making a cause of our
myself if I'm making a sales
presentation I want sitting right next
to me if I'm making a conference call
with attorneys and everybody that I want
somebody sitting right next to me or
being on the call with me
want as much exposure to be with my team
because I want to do on-the-job training
I want more PVD cells that I want more
leaders being developed out there right
on the way you do it there's one thing
to give a man you want to say here you
go go learn how to sell and go get them
the best way to do it go kit it's not
going to work on the job training number
one number two build leaders focus on
development leaders and the way you
build leaders that build remotely any
remote office or multiple locations that
succeed anything that succeed I
guarantee it succeed because there's a
leader leading that if there's no leader
it doesn't succeed it's always the case
always the case you take any company
that's extremely successful it is
extremely successful because they've
done a very good job building leaders
next this is the part most people don't
want to do most 30-yard type of leaders
which I call 30-yard type of leaders who
are control freaks they don't like to go
visit other offices because typically
this becomes their priority which is
supposed to because this is your hub but
one of these could end up being better
than your hub if you do quarterly visits
so I like to go visit quarterly the
reason why I've always liked quarterly
visits is one I stay connected to the
heartbeat to I'm building relationships
three I can see things I need to fix if
there's issues if there's challenges
that come up if I go in a place and I
notice there's a leak here we got a fix
on so glad we got here before this one
was going to be fixed oh they were
having issues financially in this area
so they had a terminal if you're going
on here with the business that they
won't even use in the sector's lead into
a ton of complaints that this could have
caused a lot of headaches later on I'm
so glad I did that but it requires
quarterly visits so someone knows it
well what if I have nine offices what if
I have five locations what if I have
this corner what about that going on use
the 90/10 rule or the Preta theory the
802 8020 rule
spend 80% of your time on the top 20% of
performing offices and develop them and
develop those remote businesses that
show because you can build them into
stronger leaders who can potentially
develop other locations as well next two
times a year do annual gatherings and
conventions where everybody
together say you have four offices four
offices all come together twice here
everybody sees everybody because people
learn from other offices people see what
other leaders are doing better than this
one they're collaborating they're
learning the cross-pollinating there's a
lot of strong strengths coming together
and this person wasn't good in this and
this girl was better at it than him he
learns from her she wasn't good at this
that this guy is very good at they learn
from together there's a lot of strength
that comes out of that next weekly
accountability calls literally weekly
accountability calls where it could go
for 90 minutes and this is how to call
start so hey what'd you do this past
week the way I like to do accountability
calls I like to do accountability calls
based on two different behaviors one is
behavior one is measurable figures each
one of them typically have four things I
want to ask for so four behaviors so it
could be this week I send this many
emails I made this many calls I did this
many appointments that are these types
of sales
I made these many appointment that are
this type of thing but I want four
activities so activity results I brought
on board this many employees I sold this
many of this product we did this much in
our office in volume and we did this ok
great
4 + 4 activity results on a weekly basis
we start off with those offices leaders
that are running we mostly give me these
reports on what they did then I ask
what's worked for everybody this week
share with the rest of us so we can
learn we did this at our office we did
that in our office we did this
phenomenon next what would you like to
process then we literally for an hour
process any subject they want to process
together so everyone learns from one
another we address issues there we bring
leaders bulletins their there's
challenges there's issues
we're solved boom next week again next
week again next week again a weekly
accountability going next daily report
the nor the leader is that's running a
remote office the more daily reports I
want the more of a veteran leader this
person becomes that they're running it
independently I only need weekly
reporting but if you're new or any daily
reporting because I don't trust you yet
I don't know who you are yet I don't
trust you running the operation all by
yourself you I need daily reporting
reporting could be same thing how much
was your activity what happened what did
you learn
here's what I did today Papapa Papapa
great 3-minute email since I know and I
look at it okay cool
good I look at all good oh there's a red
sign here red signal let me call them
then I'll call you up then I sent you
text they tell you tell me listen and
the email here what do you mean by that
can you elaborate did you figure out how
to do the typing you need to read this
book captain you need to watch this
video there's still education going on
there following two times of your fun
trips what could be a fun trip a fun
trip could be a barbecue together a fun
trip could be I put a contest together
we're going to go to a cruise we're
going to go to a trip we're going to go
to Disney World we're going to go to
Disneyland we're going to go to I don't
know show and we're going to go to a
basketball game a sporting event El
Clasico whatever it is you put it twice
a year that something fun happens where
they see you not in business I'm your
boss you better listen to me let's just
let it loose let's say yeah let's talk
let's break bread let's just talk what's
going on tell me about your family
what's going on with your life you do
that a couple times here in order for
any and I've seen this over the years
anybody who does this very effectively
anybody who does this typically very
very effectively they're very good at
accountability very good at
accountability which means you're very
good at communication but they're also
very very good at creating tools that
allows them to constantly develop and
improve so tools could be many different
things it could be an accountability
tool can be a communication tool it can
be a reference tool it can be a you know
document tool it can be a tool that
tells them how to do something can be an
educational tool it can be a Salesforce
appointment tool there's a lot of tools
notes tool ever there's a lot of tools
that you can use for everyone to know
what things are doing calendar tools but
it's got to be a tool driven Google Docs
there's so many different things that
you can use to make it a tool driven
business and a last but not least
solution to build remotely is a leaders
bulletin I'm a big fan of leaders
bulletin
I am I taught a staff meeting the other
day this was two weeks ago and it was a
very intense meeting and this is what
the staff meeting was I said I as a CEO
I am useless without numbers I don't
exist I'm a nobody you may as well fire
me and send me home if I don't have
report
I need reports I need figures I need
trends I need 24 months I need to know
what to stick this versus laughing need
to know what this thing did which does
last month I need as much reporting as
possible the more reports I have the
more I can find a leak what we're losing
money or this individual is not running
a proper opposite it can fix so leaders
bulletin or reporting allows you to make
the call to that one person that is
struggling with one area that you can
help tweak where the sales in that
office goes back up but if you have no
leaders bullets and no reporting who the
hell am i competing against how am i
measuring myself to improve what am I
going to figure out what my prior best
for me to be I can't do it so it's your
it's your responsibility as a leader who
is trying to build multiple teams in
multiple locations to have proper
reporting proper accountability proper
leaders bullets and so I know how to
improve my business so having said that
this kind of gives you a better idea for
those you guys that cannot yet duplicate
yourself on multiple different places in
your 30 yard type of a leader to figure
out a way to become remote leader where
you start building remotely and all of a
sudden you have a national business
possibly even an international business
because you figure out a way to hold
people accountable and build leaders so
if you got any questions any thoughts
any comments comment on the bottom part
let's get our pillow here was completely
gone on the other side worse throw this
lifetime here he did today we did the
stairs in Santa Monica so you should see
the way we're walking after doing the
stairs back-to-back in Santa Monica Paul
looks like he's got to use a restroom
every step he takes but his key is going
to be fine hey if you haven't subscribed
to this channel click on the button here
notification squad you guys are rock
stars if you are not part of the
notification squad click on the Lord
button right next to the subscribe
button you will also be part of the
notification squad thanks for watching
everybody take care of ice
[Music]